Alley is in Louisville Kentucky hi Ally
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks um
thanks very much for taking my call sure
what's up so I I bought the property in
Canada in 2008 and for four hundred and
seventy thousand why well because I was
stupid you were you living there you so
I yeah I lived in Canada for ten years
the US a couple of years ago okay why
didn't you sell it when you left because
it was very luck Marlo er than what I
owe to hmm yeah so it's it's worth 230
now and I've been renting it out the
rent is less you know it doesn't cost
covered the mortgage 280 it's worth 230
what's it what are you own at 470 370 I
all and I bought it for four hundred and
seventy three seventy and it's worth to
the to your hundred and forty grand in
the hole that's right Wow and yeah and
you know it this is probably the most
stupid decision that I made but I did
more of you know purchasing houses
because I think it's you know every I
moved a lot and every place that I went
the first thing I was being rushed to
bought a house and thank God I I I came
across your show a couple of months ago
and I we were gonna buy another house to
to be a school district until I listened
to your show and now I'm clear you know
I know all this decisions that I made
and now I'm wondering the good thing is
I had you know some other deaths that
are paid off just recently and I have my
twenty four thousand emergency found now
I'm not sure should I pay the five
hundred extra that I need
to cover the mortgage and then take care
of other baby steps or you're not sure
how five hundred a month you're in the
hole versus rent versus the payment on
the bad rental is that are the values
recovering on the bad can of the rental
is it going to come up eventually this
is very special this is oil and gas
field and it's been on the low downhill
for a while and I'm you know I think
they're saying it might be another two
or three years you know you're a hundred
and forty thousand in the hole and
you're burning at six thousand dollars a
year
correct which is five thousand five
hundred bucks a month and so if you burn
for two years that's twenty four
thousand that's nothing like a hundred
and forty thousand so you just sit there
and burn it you just cover I cover the
deficit until the thing comes back and
value to sell it in the meantime
use any other monies that you have we're
going to let this thing recover enough
to get you out of it that's what I want
it to do when the long guess comes back
and you bought in a very volatile
geographic area in terms of the the the
micro economy in that areas also write
all about weather or drilling for oil or
not it sounds like so ouch
Alex yeah so just run that cover the
deficit any other monies that you have
use them in your other baby steps or use
them for investing or paying off your
current residence that kind of stuff but
I wouldn't pay extra on this rental I'm
just gonna feed it the least I can
possibly feed it and be sure and raise
the rents as often as you can to maybe
you're not gonna end up the next year
maybe it won't be five hundred the whole
maybe it'll be four hundred and Holt or
something anything you can do like that
to minimize the damage this is done and
get you there